as the left embraces another hate hoax
all other distinctions fade away this is
not the party of AOC or the party of
Nancy Pelosi Democrats have become the
party of Jesse Smollett we will examine
the live-action roleplay of the left
then Republicans cheer on a o'seas new
Republican challenger but is the fresher
facer conservative in New York's 14th
congressional district just a wolf in
sheep's clothing we will examine her
current statements and her old tweets
finally a new report shows Trump hasn't
built any wall and a woman marries her
chandelier
Love Wins all that and more i'm michael
knowles and this is the michael knowles
show
[Music]
have we got a packed show today let's
jump right in
a Georgia state representative claimed
on Sunday that she was verbally
assaulted by a man in a grocery store by
a white man and do you know what he told
her allegedly he told her to go back to
where she came from that sounds very
familiar doesn't it sounds like the
chant that briefly some people at a
trump rally were chanting about Ilhan
Omar and more importantly it sounds like
the line that the mainstream media were
trying to use against all conservatives
everywhere to smear us as bigots and
xenophobes and nativists racists and
whatever issed you want to use when she
mentioned this story this state
representative I did not believe it for
even one second I just want to go on the
record
not for one nanosecond did I believe
that a man in a grocery store started
yelling at this woman to go back where
she came from a white man probably
wearing a mag ahead I knew from the
first second that this was Jesse
Smollett the Jesse smollett of the
Georgia State Assembly and guess what
turns out I was right the left believe
this they left believe this immediately
they bought it hook line and sinker why
did they believe it and why did I not
believe it it's because of different
premises about America the Left believes
that America is hopelessly racist and
bigoted and so therefore of course some
black state representative would be told
to go back to where she came from go
back to Africa in a grocery store I
don't believe that America is hopelessly
racist and bigoted I actually think that
America is the most racially tolerant
country in the history of the world we
are by fear this multiracial experiment
this this completely novel idea this
experiment in mixing different
ethnicities and cultures together all
underneath a sort of unified American
culture and American national identity
they're not a racial identity and so I
just never thought this would happen
turns out I was right the Democrats
believe this stuff and and to their
credit actually she put on a pretty good
performance her lawyer first red flag
her lawyer tweets out this video
after the alleged event happened so you
know I decided I decided to go live
because I'm very upset because people
are getting really out of control with
this with this white privilege stuff I'm
at the grocery store and I'm in the tent
out the alley says ten items or less yes
I have 15 items but I'm not most
pregnant and I can't stand up for long
this white make up his white man comes
up to me and says you lazy son of a
[ __ ] you need to go back where you came
from
so you don't even don't be up that lazy
that much pregnant this is your ignorant
okay so [ __ ] look she put on a good
performance she's crying she now she's
an elected politician elected
politicians are all actors they're all
performers so you gotta you gotta
remember that as well but what happened
I don't know what happened in the
grocery store maybe the guy called her
some mean name maybe the guy was rude
maybe he was out of line maybe he wasn't
I don't know what happened but what I am
certain of is that he did not tell her
to go back to where she came from to go
back to Africa where her ancestors came
from or something like that
it's just too perfect a political line
for Democrats right now right after they
made a whole hullabaloo about of this
Ilhan omar thing I just know that that
didn't happen and it looks like I was
right because almost immediately this
representative Erika Thomas showed her
cards she kind of admitted that the
story that she was telling on camera
wasn't quite true we'll get to that in a
second but first cellphone plans and
bills are notoriously confusing more
than confusing they're just there
they're overly expensive you sign up for
one thing and you get charged so much
more it's impossible to know what you're
actually paying for with all these
hidden fees and and all these little
fees that you know it adds up over time
and all of a sudden they become huge
costs no more thanks to men mobile mint
mobile makes it easy to cut your
wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a
month I know you don't believe me I know
because you've been burned too many
times so have I with big wireless 15
bucks a month that's it that's what I'm
telling you 15 bucks a month every plan
comes with unlimited nationwide talking
text mint mobile allows you to stop
paying for unlimited data that you're
never going to use because that is the
main tool that big big Wireless uses to
steal all your money so you can choose
between plans with 3 8 and 12 gigabytes
of 4G LTE data you don't need more than
that you buy that between your home and
your office you're on Wi-Fi most of the
day anyway you you don't need all of
that data the big Wireless are cramming
down your necks that you don't even use
use your own phone with any minute
mobile plan keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
ditch old wireless and start saving with
mint mobile get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month I know you
don't believe me
just try it out it's I'm telling you get
the plan shipped to your door for free
mint mobile comm slash Knolls KO wles
mint mobile comm slash Knolls
don't sacrifice service don't sacrifice
your phone don't sacrifice your context
just cut your wireless bill down to 15
bucks a month I'm like basically giving
you free money go to mint mobile comm
slash anoles KO wles so this Georgia
state representative Erika Thomas admits
almost immediately once she got off her
lawyer's cellphone footage that she
tweeted out once she's doing an
interview with the media they say Sohee
hold on you're telling me that this
white man in the grocery store said go
back to where you come from did that
really happen representative Thomas
here's what she says
he said go back you know those types of
words I don't want to say he said go
back to your country or more back to
where he came from
but he was making those types of
references is what
hold on wait wait wait those types of
words what what do you mean types of
words he either said go back to where
you came from or go back to your country
or go back to Africa or go but or he
didn't
what do you mean types of words what so
what's a word that's a type of word like
go about toaster they've got they both
have oor they the similar types of words
what do you mean types of words very
vague right and then she he backs off
and even further she goes I'm not gonna
say that he said go back you just said
it you said it in a teary-eyed video
that your lawyer shop that you tweeted
out obviously for a political game so
she backs off it right because it it
just seems like it was too good to be
true this shows why we should all treat
these claims of hate experiences and
hate speech and hate this and hate that
with a grain of salt then incredibly
cbs46 the local CBS affiliate in this
area gets both of these people the man
who allegedly told her to go back home
and this representative Erica Thomas
gets them together in a parking lot
to hash out what really happened and
what it turns out is the guy actually
isn't white at all and he's not a trump
supporter and he's not a Republican he's
actually a Hispanic Liberal Democrat and
he contradicts her narrative her first
narrative events I got it's not her
second narrative of events he gives what
he says is the real story on camera with
Erica Thomas here's what he says black
brown and any woman that's out there
that's nine months pregnant and a white
man comes up to you it calls you up oh I
don't care what no as you are Oh nobody
comes up to you it calls you a son of it
I have a sick man that degraded me a
berated me and I'm not crying no I'm not
I'm standing right in front of you and
if you know how you made me feel
yesterday I'm Hispanic I don't care what
she thinks she's doing it for political
purposes period like I said earlier I'm
a Democrat I will vote Democrat the rest
of my life
okay so to call me what she wants to
believe for her political purposes then
make it black white brown or whatever
it's so untrue so I looked into this a
little bit because look the guy could be
lying maybe he's lying about being
Hispanic he he certainly could pass as a
white guy but he could also he looks
kind of Hispanic - I don't who knows
he maybe he's lying about being a
Democrat maybe turns out no if you look
at his social media history he's a
Democrat just last week he was defending
the squat aoc Ayanna Presley Ilhan Omar
and Rashida to leave he was actually
defending Omar and Omar is at the center
of this this whole non traversée because
Omar was the the object of the go back
home chants send her back chants the
narrative explodes here she is the Jesse
Smollett of this week there's gonna be
another Jesse Smollett next week there's
gonna be another Jesse summit after that
because the left is living in a hoax
Fantasyland this guy whatever he said to
her he might have called her a lot of
names but what he it seems like he
didn't say go back home he's a liberal
Democrat he's Hispanic and the best part
of it all Twitter is forever the
Internet is forever four years ago now
Erika Thomas this representative tweeted
out quote going downtown Atlanta for an
event I hope I magically bump into Jesse
Smollett hashtag biggest fan
you don't say representative Thomas if
this were a Hollywood script if someone
just turned this events these are these
events into a Hollywood movie the studio
would reject it they'd say it's too
obvious it's too on-the-nose you can
have her say at the end of it that she's
a huge fan of Jesse Smollett the most
famous race hoaxes are in the country
but that's actually what happened
because we're living in the simulation
because this is the matrix because it's
just too perfect in the face of a hate
hoax like this all of the other
distinctions among Democrats and on the
left fade away this is not the party of
AOC or the party of Nancy Pelosi that's
not what unites all of them what unites
all of them
are these hate hoaxes what unites all of
them is that they see Nazis everywhere
they see concentration camps everywhere
they see racial bigotry everywhere
they're the party of Jesse Smollett it's
a party of a LARPers live-action
roleplay they're playing out of fantasy
on the media they're playing out a
fantasy in the halls of Congress it
isn't true they want to pretend that
they're fighting the great civil rights
battles that were already fought and
finished 50 years ago or more a hundred
years ago or more 150 years ago they're
they're playing that because right now
basically in the grand scheme of things
we don't have any problems we don't have
real problems so we have to invent fake
verbal attacks fake racial hate hoaxes
at at grocery stores we have to invent
white Trump supporters out of Hispanic
liberal Democrats out of Hispanic
liberal Democrats who defend Ilhan Omar
it's a fantasy and as long as the
Democrats by the way are living in a
fantasy the GOP is going to have a
strong electoral advantage this is how I
think a lot of how Trump won in 2016 and
why he's looking good for 2020 is
because you had the left living in this
fantasy world of evil racists half the
country are deplorable irredeemable
bigots and we looked around we said that
isn't true we're the most racially
tolerant country in the history of the
world it's cut through that BS if you
campaign on fantasy you're probably not
going to win if you campaign on reality
you have a better chance of winning this
is why AOC in New York's 14th
congressional district is facing a new
challenger although there is something a
little wrong I think with this challenge
your campaign and I want to get into it
because I don't want conservatives and
Republicans to to be taken in by a wolf
in sheep's clothing if that's what she
is so moving from Georgia to New York's
14th over in Queens in the Bronx the
socialist darling who's really from
Northern Westchester but she pretends
she's Jenny from the block
AOC has a new GOP challenger shiri
Murray and everyone on the right is
really excited about this because she's
a woman because she's an ethnic minority
the
because she's an immigrant from Jamaica
because she just checks all these boxes
like we fall into it two on the right
the left focuses on all identity
politics the the left focus is on all of
the intersectional boxes and we rightly
say that that's stupid the politics
isn't about those superficial
characteristics it's about ideas and
it's about the country and it's about
may the best person win regardless of
their skin color or their genitals but
we fall into it too because we think mmm
a o'seas campaigning on all those
identity politics
maybe if we campaign on that we can win
I think it's kind of silly but sometimes
look III understand why it's effective
to us because it shuts down most of
AFC's arguments sometimes in our
excitement I think we don't do our due
diligence here so this woman she
remotely Amory rather has been doing the
rounds on Fox News and doing the rounds
on social media here is Murray
explaining her campaign on Hannity well
it's disgusting I think the narrative on
the national level needs to be dialed
back and that's why I'm in the race I'd
like to represent the constituents in
Queens and the Bronx and we see AOC from
the time she's been elected she put out
policy like the job-killing green New
Deal
she then went on to kill the Amazon deal
in New York which would have put some
25,000 jobs in Queens and so these are
some of the reasons along with kitchen
table issues that I do believe that a OC
has neglected in her limelight bid to
focus on in the congressional district
so this is a little bit vague isn't it
she's saying she doesn't like the
job-killing green New Deal and she
doesn't like the job-killing Amazon deal
that aoc AOS who shut down the Amazon
deal and took away about twenty five
thousand jobs from around her district
it's a little vague the problem with the
green new deal isn't just that it kills
jobs it's that it's it costs ninety
three trillion dollars it's that it
won't really do anything to help the
environment it's that it knocks down all
of our buildings it's that it outlaws
cars and airplanes and cows and it takes
away our personal choice and it's that
it becomes a transfer program for
federal funds to people based on their
race or their sex or all these strange
characteristics it's that it's it's
profoundly unamerican
and that it's socialist and the problem
isn't just the jobs what you'll notice
when politicians when all they talk
about is job-killing and they're really
vague on cultural questions usually it
means they don't agree with you on
culture and they're trying to hide
something about their political views
whereas President Trump talked about
jobs a lot but he always couched it in
culture he said we're gonna love America
we're gonna stop criminals from coming
into this country we're gonna kill
terrorists we're going to stop socialism
you know he used pretty specific
language sometimes a little too specific
probably when it comes to President
Trump but at least he was telling you
where he came from so it's a bit vague
Hannity asks her to get a bit more
specific and she fails to do that how
would you describe yourself politically
and and how do you feel about President
Trump in the two plus years is
two-and-a-half years he's been in office
well I migrated here from Jamaica and I
know firsthand what it is to not just be
an immigrant but to go through the
process right and so what do I think
about what the president is doing I
think that the president is delivering
on his promises when he got elected huh
come again
he said please describe your politics
please tell us what you think of the
president and she said I think president
Trump is delivering on his promises when
he got elected that's largely true but
it
doesn't answer the either of the
questions that Hannity asked she never
describes yourself politically she never
explains what she thinks about Donald
Trump
delivering on his promises okay this
kind of confirmed my suspicions when I
saw it but then we found out some really
bad news Murray celebrated when a OC won
her primary election last year she
celebrated when AOC beat Joe Crowley in
the Democratic primary not ten years ago
not five years ago one year ago she
tweeted out an article the article was
titled a 28 year old Democratic
Socialist just out stood a powerful
powerful ten term congressman in New
York and and this woman she reamer II
the GOP candidate for Congress tweeted
out quote congratulations Alexandria
Queens is headed in a new direction and
it's time for new leadership hashtag yes
all right that's not great I guess there
are some possible explanations for this
it could be that she wanted to shake up
the Democratic establishment okay that's
fair enough this would be like a kind of
acceleration estai dia you want you want
the the most radical people in your
opponents party to come out because
it'll show how crazy they are and then
Republicans are more likely to win now I
don't know I mean she said Queens is
headed in a new direction was obviously
headed to AOC so it was headed in the
direction of socialism that's probably
not great hashtag yes that's not great
the only other explanation is that she
didn't know that AOC was a radical
socialist but that one falls apart
because the article she tweeted out
identified aoc as socialist now how is I
was sharing more we gonna answer this
the answer she gives us pretty weak
sauce she gave this classic answer that
politicians who either don't believe in
anything or who don't want you to know
what they believe give the answer she
gave was a tweet quote I was hopeful
when AOC won she took on a democratic
political machine and won but nothing
has changed since why because she's only
been focused on fame and politics of
division and hate we deserve and
expected better that's why I'm running
join us you were hopeful when a
socialist won the primary
you were hopeful when a
radical-socialist beat a relatively more
moderate democrat what what about that
made you hopeful what were you hoping
for I mean this is the classic and it's
a smart answer in the sense that some
people who are centrist politically or
more moderate who don't pay attention to
politics you could see them saying look
I was hopeful when Obama won that he
would be good but then he was bad I had
no actually a number of people who are
now Trump supporters who said that I was
hopeful when Obama won but he wasn't
good and so I had now I'm more
conservative part of the reason it's
plausible with Obama is Obama only spoke
in vague terms hope and change you know
kind of like the terms that cheery
Murray's talking him but aoc didn't
speak in vague terms she said I'm a
socialist and I want socialism that's
what she campaigned on so what were you
hopeful for you were hopeful that she
would be socialist right and then she
wasn't I mean what do you mean you were
hopeful that something would happen and
then nothing has changed the only thing
that AOC would change is that she would
make the country more socialist change
in itself isn't good you change in one
direction or the other if she made the
country more American more conservative
made us more economically competitive
made us love our country more that would
be a good thing but if she did the
things she said she was going to do
which you said you were hoping for then
that would make the country much worse
that change would be terrible doesn't
make a lot of sense last year she
celebrate a socialist winning an
election but now she knows better is
that what she's saying either she's
still a left winger or just twelve
months ago she exhibited egregious
judgment and ignorant either way this is
a bad sign now I'm I'm interested in
this race because a Oh see and I grew up
in exactly the same place we grew up one
town apart from each other at exactly
the same time we're the same age and
we've had similar life experiences so
I'm curious about it I'm also curious
about it because a or C and I have spent
about the same amount of time in her
current congressional district and I'm
interested in it because this is she is
the leader of the Democratic Party right
I mean she is the fresh-faced DNC
chairman Tom Perez said she's the future
the party she gets all the media
attention so this is gonna be an
important race and I just don't want
conservatives and Republicans to get
hoodwinked by a fraud I'm not saying
that Murray is definitely a fraud I'm
saying there are a lot of questions
about her so if if Miss Murray wants to
come on the show and talk about it I'd
be happy to have her on but she's got a
lot of answers to give she's got a lot
of explaining to do there are other
Republicans in this race and I just
don't want conservatives to fall into
that trap of saying oh look she checks
all of the intersectional boxes she'll
be really good to run against aoc when
in fact she may be quite left-wing
herself much more left-wing than other
people in the race we'll just have to
follow it and if Miss Murray wants to
come on the show she's more than welcome
in even crazier news than aoc I know
it's hard to imagine anything crazier
than aoc but in the realm of news that
is crazier than Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
a woman is marrying her 91 year old
chandelier that's that I almost could
end the show right there but no let's
look into it it's a bit of a
may-december relationship obviously the
chandelier is much older than the 35
year old woman but love is love you know
hashtag and love wins hashtag hashtag
and this woman obviously has a right to
marry her love right here she is
explaining her nuptials just like
anybody who falls in love with somebody
else they want to be close to them and
so I enjoy being close to my chandeliers
I've admired them for years I love the
way that they've looked and looked the
way that the light catches on the little
crystals and I've just loved them in
general I think the beautiful thing I
think it's good in the world to have a
bit of variety in how different types of
people who were all the same well would
be a really boring place all right
that's Amanda Liberty her name is Amanda
Liberty it used to be a man to Whitaker
but she changed her name to Amanda
Liberty a number of years ago when she
entered into a
different romantic relationship she
entered into a long-distance
relationship with I'll give you five
seconds to guess her name is Amanda
Liberty who was she in a long-distance
relationship with she was in a
long-distance relationship with the
Statue of Liberty
here she is then when I met Lady Liberty
the flags already knew another
friendship with Lady P they were already
friends so I wasn't it didn't feel like
I was cheating on anybody the first part
Libby that I fell in love with was a
crown and a torch as well but it was a
crown that initially got me attracted to
her I just want to be able to tell
people that I love him because I am
proud of loving her I am really proud to
have him I'm really proud that she's
part of my life she's proud didn't we
just celebrate pride Pride Month
didn't we just celebrate all the
different sorts of sexual identity and
gender identity and sexual attraction
this woman actually does have a sexual
orientation that is recognized which is
the sexual orientation toward inanimate
objects obviously she seems a little
crazy does that maybe that's hate speech
if I say that she seems a little crazy
maybe I'll get kicked off of youtube if
I say she seems a little crazy we will
examine the similarities and differences
between late Chris Whitaker Liberty or
Amanda Liberty's attraction to famous
statues and 91 year old chandeliers and
the rest of our sexual morality will
explain why this is the logical or
illogical I guess conclusion of so much
of the left to view on sex then we will
explain the greatest irony of the 2020
race and has to do with Bernie Sanders's
campaign and then finally a masterstroke
from President Trump on Twitter which
the mainstream media obviously are
ignoring a lot of the conservative media
are ignoring it I think too the the
conservative movements peril will
explain why President Trump is so
interested in ASAP rocky dollar sign
wrapper we'll get to that in a second
but first you got to go to daily
wire.com ten dollars per month
one hundred dollars for an annual
membership what do you get what don't
you get you get me you get the and
reclaim and show you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get the map will show you you
get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up on Thursday you get to ask
questions backstage you get another
Kingdom you get all of it and you get
the leftist tears tumblr this is really
mmm that's really good
it tastes like exposing their hate
hoaxes that's what it tastes like the
feeling of exposing their ridiculous
divisive narratives like it for instance
if I were walking in South Central
Chicago in the middle of the night you
know and I had walk in there and I I had
some people in maggots come up to me and
tell me this is maggot country and beat
me up I would not drop my left is tears
tumblr I couldn't because when those
hoaxes are exposed I got to catch those
tears or I will drown go to daily wire
comm we've got a lot more we'll be right
back
this woman Amanda Liberty I wonder if
she'll change her name to the chandelier
the chandeliers name is Lumiere like in
the movie Beauty and the Beast so maybe
she'll become Amanda Lumiere after this
she says that she's really proud of her
attraction to inanimate objects to Lady
Liberty into the chandelier she has an
open relationship with the chandelier
she sleeps with different chandeliers in
her bed every night that's not a joke
she actually does that I don't mean to
make fun of a crazy woman she's
obviously very mentally unbalanced it's
probably not good for these journalists
in the UK to go into her house and film
her because she is a crazy person
however it's instructive for our culture
because this is a devastating report for
the love is love sexuality for the love
is love view of sexual morality hashtag
Love Wins
this woman describes her marriage to a
chandelier in precisely the same way in
which the left describes the evolving
definitions of sex and gender right down
to the emphasis on the word pride I'm so
proud of it she says quote I'm
determined to have this commitment
ceremony
to prove that I'm here for Lumiere and
that my love is going to last I know a
lot of people think my attraction to
chandeliers is strange but I'm not crazy
obviously she's crazy but she's no
crazier than a man who says he's a woman
she's no crazier than a man who feels in
some metaphysical way that he wants to
be a woman and I'm not even using crazy
as a pejorative term I'm saying he's got
something wrong in his psychology and he
should be treated for it and we should
treat this woman for it and we should be
compassionate toward her but we
shouldn't indulge her fantasy that she's
married to a 91 chandelier any more than
we should indulge the fantasy then a man
a grown man is secretly a six-year-old
girl and therefore should go into the
little girl's changing room or the girls
bathroom because that isn't true as far
as I can tell there are three main
premises of the new
concept of sexual morality we've
discarded traditional sexual morality
theology of the body to trick
traditional sexual mores we threw that
away in the 1960s that's gone for most
of the pop culture so what is the new
sexual morality I think it's got three
premises one other than pedophilia and
bestiality all sexual desires are good
this is the love is love idea for some
reason pedophilia and bestiality are
excluded but everything else love is
love every other sexual desire is not
not only not bad not only neutral it's
actually positively good why is that
well it's because of the second premise
no sexual desire other than pedophilia
and bestiality should ever be repressed
you should never if you have some sexual
desire whether it's to sleep with
another person who isn't your wife or
whether it's to I don't know do whatever
you want to do it should never be
repressed this is the Love Wins idea of
sexual morality and then the third
premise is if it doesn't hurt anyone
else and it feels good do it and
actually you've got to even sort of
modify that third premise because you
can hurt each other I mean people
embrace Fifty Shades of Grey
BDSM sadomasochism so really what you
would say is if it doesn't hurt anyone
else without his or her consent and it
feels good do it and we there are still
these the the left still looks down on
pedophilia and bestiality although
you're seeing in kind of these far left
academic conferences a movement afoot to
normalize pedophilia as well obviously
you've got pedophilia in the news
because of the Jeffrey Epstein underage
sex trafficking scandal that is
apparently ensnared Bill Clinton who
flew on Jeffrey Epstein she had 27 times
even though the jet was nicknamed the
Lolita Express those are the three
premises though okay this woman is
embracing all of those premises she says
quote people often can't understand that
this is just a natural orientation for
me look at those words natural
orientation I was born this way it's my
or
it's not my desire it's not my
preference it's my orientation I'm
fundamentally oriented to want to sleep
with a 91 year old chandelier well if
you're fundamentally oriented that way
you can't change it she goes on that I
can find the beauty in objects and can
sense their energy because she's finding
this beauty how dare you frown on beauty
she senses their energy maybe you can't
sense their energy but she can don't
erase her lived experience
don't deny her truth she goes on I'm not
hurting anyone by entering into a
relationship with them
I am simply just following my heart here
it is I'm not hurting anyone if she's
not hurting anyone what's it to you who
were you to say that this is harmful
look there are plenty of normal
relationships that are really harmful
they're probably a lot worse than her
relationship to the chandelier why not
just let her alone
it's not she's not hurting anyone else
she might be hurting herself she might
be living in a fantasy and deluding
herself but she's not hurting anyone
else so who cares using the current
sexual morality can you explain why
that's wrong what she said you know I'm
not saying using traditional views of
sexual morality I'm saying using the
current popular view you can't you can't
say she's wrong
so that leaves two options either you
can conclude that what she's doing
marrying a chandelier is not wrong or
you can conclude that the current sexual
morality is somehow lacking the current
sexual morality is insufficient to
describe reality I have a feeling that
as a culture what we're gonna do is just
say you know there's nothing really
wrong with marrying a chandelier because
that's easier and you don't have to tell
someone that their desires ought to be
repressed or that their desires are
wrong in order to speak about this in a
serious way in a way that has something
to do with the truth in the way that we
all know on a base level that you
shouldn't marry a 91 year old chandelier
that actually there's no such thing as
marrying a 91 year old chandelier in
order to speak about this you need to be
able to speak about ordered and
disordered desires not every one of my
desires is good some of them are bad
many of them are bad that means that we
need to be able to speak about purpose
what your love is made for what your
love is ordered to
word your love is not made for 91 year
old chandeliers your sexual desires are
not made for the Lady Liberty statue
that means that we need to be able to
speak about objective truth you can't
marry a chandelier whatever the
definition of marriage is it's oh it's
never involved chandeliers all we have
left in our culture is sentimentality
we have Hallmark card culture I love
this I sense the beauty of this I sense
the energy of this I'm not hurting
anyone love is love love wins if we
can't come up with an answer if we can't
be mature and discuss serious things
love joy purpose Tilos the good religion
culture if we can't talk about those
things like adults then we're all going
to start marrying chandeliers we're good
maybe we'll at least be in a culture
where people are marrying chandeliers
you know what this woman is saying is
the sort of thing that a three-year-old
would say say I love my teddy bear I
want to marry my teddy bear say oh
that's cute it's cute when a two year
old or three year old says that it's not
so cute when a 35 year old says that but
our culture because we are largely
uneducated and largely uncultured and
I'm not this is not a knock on anybody
this is true throughout society in many
ways the so-called elites are the least
educated people among us we're all
behaving like overgrown children we're
living in a very childish culture and
you're gonna see a lot more chandelier
weddings on the realm of actual hard
real politics of people trying to behave
like adults but maybe it doesn't quite
happen let's turn to a serious serious
hardcore urgent immediate political
problem the problem on our southern
border it turns out according to a
report now from US Customs and Border
Protection President Trump has not built
a single mile of new fencing since he's
been in office
that's according to maybe there's
another report that will contradict that
but according to US Customs and Border
Protection all the fencing that has been
built since Trump was elected has been
built in place of dilapidated designs
fifty-one miles have been built with the
money set aside in 2017 and 2018 this
has only replaced outdated walls since
Trump took office they've built 1.7
miles on average per month none in areas
that previously lacked fencing 205 miles
of new and replacement wall has been
funded since Trump took office now in
their defense why have they only focused
on replacing walls rather than building
new walls it's because it's way easier
to replace the walls not just the
Democrats in Congress obstructing it but
the environmental laws the regulations
from the EPA the regulations from the
bureaucracy what we call the deep state
it's much easier to get the
environmental and zoning permits in the
areas that already have walls then to
get them elsewhere even five feet of new
fencing
this shows the immense difficulty of
building the wall nevertheless President
Trump needs to come up with a plan here
and he needs to build that wall he has
to do it he keeps insisting that he's
built a lot of the wall here's President
Trump back in February
[Applause]
now you really mean finished that wall
because we've built a lot of history
stuff it's a good line I wish it were
true but it isn't true he's built he's
rebuilt portions of the wall but he has
not built a new wall and eventually
people are going to notice that there's
no new wall maybe now maybe it's
happening right now Trump has been very
good at fulfilling campaign promises but
this was a key promise of his campaign
and he hasn't done it and it's gonna be
a glaring weakness in 2020 unless he
comes up with an answer to it unless he
starts breaking ground on new wall
unless he can reframe this issue I it's
it's really depressing news but it's
it's why you've you you don't want to
over promise and under deliver you it's
fine to make big promises you've got to
fulfill them this is not one of those
issues where Trump is going to be able
to get away with it where he's going to
be able to say well we meant we really
meant rebuilding old walls no you have
to build new wall
I know it's hard the White House has my
sympathy yeah it's hard to be the
president it's hard it's hard and when
you make those promises you've got to
fulfill them that people are gonna be
chanting build the wall finish the wall
if there's no wall they're all gonna
look like we have egg on our face bad
position to be in the White House needs
to put some focus on this now this is
not to recommend any of the left-wing
presidential campaigns or the Democrat
presidential campaigns they are almost
all falling apart and the best story the
best one of all is in the Bernie Sanders
campaign there is a noose report out
that shows that Bernie Sanders the
socialist he wants $15 minimum wage for
everyone pay everybody as much money as
we can he is not paying his own campaign
staffers very much he's paying them less
than he wants the minimum wage to be
what a hypocrite now look when I saw the
report that he's not paying his staffers
much okay that's not a big deal first of
all campaign work is often very basic
work so now it's not worth $15 an hour
if you're just passing out pamphlets or
putting up your designs or something
it's actually not it's very basic work
that virtually anyone can do if they're
motivated to do it a lot of people on
campaigns volunteer because they
actually care about it right
campaigns are not motivated by making a
profit or their they shouldn't be at
least they're supposed to be nonprofit
organizations that are supposed to be
motivated by activism rather than money
the campaigns don't have much money to
begin with they want to use it carefully
they want to use it most van media buys
my first campaign that I ever worked on
I made on average seventy-five cents per
hour and that was about right that's
what they should have paid because
campaigns have to run lean the trouble
is the hypocrisy the trouble is Bernie
is running on a $15 minimum wage and he
won't extend that courtesy to his own
employees so last Thursday night
his staff leaks this story to the press
that they've unionized and they're
fighting for the $15 minimum wage and
Bernie the fake Union champion is
fighting them on it he's trying to crush
their union
so after this leaks to the press it gets
even better because the Bernie campaign
responds and says it is disrespectful to
the bargaining unit that put so much
work into this process that someone
would take their concerns and go to the
press
whatever happened to democracy dies in
darkness whatever happened to
transparency get it all out they're very
different when it affects a left-wing
campaign now that's not even the best
part of the story that Bernie doesn't
practice what he preached that like all
socialists that he's a total hypocrite
the best part of the story is now that
this has come to the press's attention
and the public's attention Bernie has to
give them $15 if he's not gonna look
like a total fraud but there's only so
much money so how is he gonna do this
he's promised he'll pay his workers $15
an hour and cut their hours he's doing
this is showing you what happens under
socialism he's showing you what happens
when you raise the minimum wage there's
only one true minimum wage it's zero
dollars an hour you're not entitled to a
job at a company or on a campaign she's
saying okay we'll give you $15 an hour
but we're not magically gonna make more
money up here so we're just gonna have
to cut your hours big win for labor
right no it's actually a big loss for
labour because they're losing he's not
paying them any more money he's just
taking away their opportunities to work
and by the way the purpose of working on
a campaign is not to make money there
are a lot easier ways to make money it's
to get experience it's to network it's
to push forward your
ideas he says quote I'm very proud to be
the first presidential candidate to
recognize a union and negotiate a union
contract well turns out Bernie's
learning about socialism for the first
time right he's always talks about
socialism his whole life the reason he's
never learned about socialism is because
he has always failed to implement his
ideas he's been in the government for
about 50 years
he's never implemented any of his ideas
right he's just is transformed
ideologically the Democratic Party it's
now ideologically his party but he's
never actually affected any of his ideas
so he's never he's never dealt with the
consequences of them now he's learning
in real time that his ideas don't work
money doesn't just come from the sky
that you you can't just raise the
minimum wage without any consequence and
then actually raising the so-called
minimum wage Oh often if not always
hurts the people that it's intended to
help before we go I have to talk about
this ASAP rocky tweet President Trump
sent out a tweet over the weekend that
is his most popular tweet of all time
sighs sometimes wonder if dead loved
ones came back to life and I had to
explain to them all the craziness that's
happened since they've been go on what
what I would tell them first I would
read them this tweet that's how I would
explain all of it this is from President
Trump quote just spoke to Kanye West
about his friend ASAP Rocky's
incarceration I will be calling the very
talented prime minister of Sweden to see
what we can do about helping ASAP rocky
so many people would like to see this
quickly resolved it's a stunning tweet I
mean so many people I don't even know
who ASAP Rocky is I barely know who
Kanye West is this is Trump's most
popular tweet of all time two hundred
nine thousand retweets seven hundred
twenty-nine thousand likes I mean in a
very technical way this is by far the
most popular tweet he's ever sent and it
shows you Trump's superpower which is
the culture so ASAP rocky got or he was
arrested in Sweden because his team got
into a fight with some guys who looked
like they had been harassing ASAP rocky
and Trump gets involved in this he is
the most pop culture aware president
since Reagan and even more than Reagan
because when Reagan was in the White
House he was piling around with Sinatra
and Jimmy Stewart
he was paddling around with stories of
an earlier era Trump is paddling around
with kanye west and calling about ASAP
Rocky is so in the culture and it shows
you look I don't I don't know I said
Rocky I don't listen to his music I
don't know anything he's ever saying I
barely listen to any Kanye West this is
true of most people who spend their life
in politics because you're just focused
on politics all the time and you're not
especially conservatives you're not
listening to hip-hop a lot or rap but we
have to be aware of something we have to
be aware of our blindness most people
don't care about Kamala Harris's health
care plan most people have no idea what
it is and have never thought about it
for two seconds but most people in the
pop culture know who ASAP Rocky is most
people care a lot more that a guy named
ASAP Rocky is in a Swedish prison then
that Camilla Harris might abolish
private health insurance Justin Bieber's
now talking about Tyga all these
different guys in pop culture of
boycotting Sweden to help their friend
ASAP rocky and this goes down through
the culture Trump is the proof of the
Breitbart Andrew Breitbart slogan
politics is downstream of culture he is
the culture and for those conservatives
especially who say Oh Trump stop
tweeting about ASAP Rocky and Kanye
forget about Kanye who cares you are
missing politics politics is the art of
inclusion politics is the art of
popularity and this tweet about ASAP
rocky and Kanye West is the most popular
thing the president has ever tweeted he
gets it maybe this guy I know it's so
hard for those of us to believe who
those of us who talk about politics all
the time this guy maybe he knows what
he's doing maybe president Trump knows
how to bring people together maybe he
knows how to talk to a whole group of
Americans maybe the majority of
Americans in a way that is obviously
political but in a way that isn't just
harping on the same old dry wonky think
tank luncheon kind of topics that have
led other conservatives to fail at
elections you know people knock Trump
for watching Fox News too much not going
to enough luncheons that think too
they knock him for watch it forgetting
all his news from Fox and Friends or
wherever between a luncheon at a
think-tank and Fox and Friends between
reading the latest dissertation in some
intellectual political journal and
listening to ASAP rocky and talking to
Kanye West guess which gives you the
better pulse on politics we talked about
the difference between fantasy world and
reality
this affects conservatives in politics
too because I think we have this fantasy
world of politics where everything that
matters is about intellectual
dissertations in political journals
journals of political philosophy the
Democrat fantasy world is that it's this
awful racial bigoted maniac place not
you know Nazis everywhere the reality of
it is a lot closer to we love our
country we like our flag and a lot of
Americans like ASAP rocky President
Trump is tapping into that it's a little
weird for those of us who don't care
about the pop culture that much you
don't care about hip-hop but maybe the
guy is on to something maybe Andrew
Breitbart was on to something too that's
our show tune in tomorrow we got a lot
more to get to we'll have to do it
tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show a
Democratic lawmaker claims that she was
the victim of a racist verbal assault at
the grocery store the media bought her
story of course Democrats bought her
story the left was running with it and
then it turns out shockingly twist
ending
there is more to the story than she
originally led on so we're going to talk
about that today also
a man in Canada is trying to legally
force women to touch his genitals
and he might actually succeed in in his
quest because he claims to be a woman
himself this is a insane just absolutely
crazy case we'll talk about it today
over on the Matt Walsh show